should the rainbow have room for an
animal costume yes they got the hots for
dressing up like mascots I speak of
furries a group of people who dress up
like anthromo blah blah blah anthrop
anthropomorphic cartoon creatures that
was hard for their own gratification
think of high school mascots but there's
no high school yet still plenty of
wedgies and body odor
our audience is really confused
so there are because they're always in
costume you may not know who a furry is
it could be anyone perhaps someone you
know
[Laughter]
what's that slide doing there anyway
seventy percent of this furry fandom
identify as lgbtq and 25 percent are
gender diverse a hundred percent
identify as sweaty
many believe being accepted as a furry
has helped him accept their sexuality
and gender identity and now activists
are pushing for acceptance of furries to
be part of Club alphabet as pink news
reports furry isn't a sexuality or
gender but there is an overlap between
the lgbtq plus community and the Furry
fandom if there's one thing to know
about their Community it's that there is
a beautiful breath of creativity and
inclusivity that has helped many to get
to know themselves better well think of
all that inclusivity then think of the
dry cleaning
the co-founder of the international
Anthem
research project I can't say that word
nobody can I don't think so they say
there's Biden can't
I said one word he got
[Applause]
now they say there's a history of
bullying faced by furries especially
when they're taken to get spayed or
neutered
and while many deny there's anything
sexual about dressing up like a giant
Fox One Night 2019 study found almost
all were driven by some degree of sexual
motivation driven by some degree of
sexual motivation sounds like my fan
base
foreign
so will
lgbtqia plus include an F now for furry
who knows but imagine where all this is
headed
hey Ted how's the wife man say I've been
wanting to talk to you about that sales
pitch you did on Friday absolutely great
job but I think we need to have a
conversation about some of the newer
employees in the office honestly they're
giving me the creeps whoa hey excuse me
where do you think you're going pervert
um the bathroom this is an lgbtqia alpha
beta Gamma Delta epsilona Capital
Omicron pyro Sigma times I Omega plus
bathroom
what it means no women in any part of
the building
I'm so sorry you had to see that women
am I right
before we get into the the kind of the
social ramifications of this are you a
furry
no it's okay nor uh no we do not judge I
know we don't once again on occasion
will put on a costume it's your endless
racist assumption the British people are
perverts I know
[Music]
um
the rumor didn't start from nowhere yeah
anyhow
I I have to by the way this isn't what
the guys in Times Square are are they no
they make money off that so those are
criminals yeah
yeah that's it
and there's no overlap there's no
overlap no I am I'm a little confused
about the furries thing and uh look
things that you just quoted to think
pink news is like a dead publication
that's a website with some people who've
got to make themselves some money and
they pretend that they're still a cause
and the chords is done but they're
forever trying to continue the hustle uh
they did it with the Trans stuff trans
has nothing to do with the people who
are gay and this has nothing to do with
anyone else the idea that somebody just
happens to be gay now has to be stuck in
an alphabet soup with a guy who wants to
put on a wolf costume it's just like No
And but but the people who that what
they don't realize is these kind of
these kind of activists they say the
cause they were after is one the
equality thing is there for gay people
but there's just this endless thing
endlessly wanting to add I mean even but
they even put um what is it asexual in
this alphabet soon really if there's one
if there are two groups have nothing in
common I can tell you gay men and
asexuals
nothing in common they're all the gay
men would just try to turn the asexuals
if I'm like what asexuals go to a bar
and talk about how much they don't like
sex yes
no they just marry me oh
[Music]
wow I'm sorry
I I didn't know I was treading on woons
no you're not oh okay
she doesn't watch we're good
Tyrus Tyrus uh if you uh I was gonna I'm
afraid to ask what kind of furry you
would be but um Do You Believe oh that's
easy grown ass man yes
and I don't fit in any of the costumes
so they can have their little Soiree
group I'm not coming so
what's another letter right isn't it all
about inclusion and acceptance and we
have to accept all the little letters
and ideas and pronouns welcome to the
game you guys have to too so come on in
furries the creepy water is fine go
right in there put the F in there you
know hey we have to be all accepting and
whatever our personal beliefs are or
wants our accountability it's shame on
us so shame on you guys let the furries
in just get one of those roller things
yes I already go to the bathroom but
maybe that's not a problem you know what
you just yeah maybe it's you just you
got you just wanted to somehow segue
this to you want to ask the furry one
question yes how do you go the only
question do you take the furry off to go
to the bathroom or do you leave it on
yes chat you want to cat um you've
traveled at some interesting uh groups
uh did you ever date a furry
come on that I know of see what I mean
maybe he didn't share it with you maybe
not maybe that's why it didn't work out
[Laughter]
was into this that would be like their
business and okay as long as they like
didn't you know get so busy with all
their little furry friends that they
stopped texting me back how do you text
when you're ready right then we'd have a
real problem yeah that's why I couldn't
do it actually you couldn't text me back
with your hands like that yeah I wonder
if they have like little little holes
for their fingers this is a good trouble
I just come up with a business idea yeah
you did textable gloves and furry
costumes yes so that like you oh like
that way you oh I didn't miss the orgy I
just didn't text you back I have your
answer yes and I think you can afford
that apartment no yeah hell yeah I'm
Gonna Be Rich you know uh
um Emily uh remember that uh We've
covered this teacher in Ontario who
identifies as a woman when in fact
they're already mad in fact it's a
fetish she has these giant breasts it's
a fetish how long before this identity
is then of course and going to be in the
workplace because you identify it's a
fetish obviously this is a fetish this
isn't an identity but we're now
embracing fetishes as identity
the problem I see is not that I agree
with you if it was just a few people
doing their own thing of course who
cares if it was anyone doing their own
thing of course who cares the problem
that I see is that this has been
embraced by the government
why the hell do you think China and
everyone else is flying in our Sovereign
airspace on our watch it's because this
the furries
yes yes because things like this are
what everyone is talking about because
this is what is a primary influence to
your point the causes that people are
rallying behind the protests that
they're out in the streets about it's
not actually moving the needle with our
government it's not actually moving the
needle with corrupt multi-millions or
actually having the value of the dollar
be somewhat equatable to a dollar no
it's stupid stuff like this and the
thing is the reason it's been embraced
by the government as well it's totally
infiltrated all of our intelligence
agencies our defense agencies all day
long they're sending emails about here's
the flag and here's how you can connect
and here's how you can support they're
being trained on this woke inclusion the
alphabet soup every day all day on
anything but protecting our nation on
anything but Civics on anything but the
Constitution so this type of massive
distraction to me has had real world
consequences far beyond just a sliver of
the population doing something sort of
weird or stupid I need to give you an
award for your ability to link furries
to like spy balloons 100
[Applause]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else